I did a little bit of tweeting yesterday
as one does and I was talking a bit
about my anxiety and depression which
are things that I have now you know that
it's been a long road for me
figuring out kind of what on earth has
been going on with my brain I've had
anxiety I think all my life and
depression started when I was around 16
I want to say which coincidentally is
what I started YouTube don't know if
those two things are connected but free
chill out and for a long time I just
sort of felt like those were just things
that I was like I was just an anxious
person I was just a bit of a depressed
person sometimes but I also didn't
really feel comfortable kind of
admitting that I had any real problems
you know I honestly just thought I
always being you know bit whiny you know
I thought it's not that I'm depressed
I'm just lazy it's not that I'm you know
anxious and I'm just a bit scared that's
where Anna dieter you know man up and
deal with it part the reason I'm so
nervous to talk about this topic as well
is because there is a kind of a certain
amount of bumming out who you're allowed
to do on YouTube it feels like it's okay
to have problems in videos so long as
you can find a way to say at the end
that you you know you gain through you
know you got to find the upside in the
first week that I posted with anxiety at
least I don't know it was a way I could
kind of like make it like a fun like
relatable type of thing it just feels
like the sort of thing you need to do it
shouldn't be the way that it is but that
was I feeling initially whereas with
depression it's just not fun to go
through that at all there's no way to
share that and be like but we're getting
through guys and everything's gonna be
fine you just feel like and then
you get through eventually but that's
not the kind of thing that people want
to hear a lot of the time I don't think
it has only been recently that I have
been like formally diagnosed with these
and to be honest the first time I went
to see a doctor about it I kind of got
my brushed off he was like is probably
isn't the big deal so maybe go see a
therapist if he can but and they didn't
really feel right to because I went to a
different doctor and she formally
diagnosed me with anxiety and depression
and I'm on medication for as well
personally I don't feel like I could get
by if I was just taking Medicaid
I also see a therapist I also try and do
things that I know will make me feel
better but it's you know it's a case of
whatever works for you I don't feel like
I would ever like its images like this
one that you see and you're just like
well come on yes like sometimes for me
going out on a walk in the nature acts
as an antidepressant sure it doesn't
always work like that
but I also need to take medication to
reach a certain baseline but that's just
me personally whatever
the one thing that medication really did
help me realize though was that it was
an illness it was a very kind of
physical way of being like you are
taking a pill for an issue that you have
so it's not a part of you and separating
those two things me from the illness was
very important for me personally when I
posted the tweets initially I think the
thing that I thought I was doing was
letting other people know hey this is a
problem that I have so if you have it
too we can go through this together I
thought I was doing it to try and like
help other people but what actually
happened was that I just got a really
big outpouring of support from people on
Twitter and I haven't experienced in
awhile and it genuinely made me feel
better I think part of this is just
wanting to really try and be as honest
and authentic as I can I still kind of
really believe that that's important
especially kind of on YouTube these days
where I feel like a lot of people do
have this weird kind of like
manufactured authenticity like it's like
a phony version of feeling like you're
connecting with someone and I don't like
that I'm kind of one of relatives there
even if it does mean I bump people out I
just really want to be like this real
this way I'm anyway I'm in Toronto
that's why this is some in an air B&B
right now last time I was here I
actually had some real problems with my
anxiety I remember once I all I had to
do was go out and get lunch and it took
me like a good hour of like sitting and
like hyperventilating what are all of
the things that could possibly go wrong
if I go out and get some lunch if I come
to a restaurant I haven't been to before
it's like yeah rationally doesn't make
any sense but for me at the time it was
like genuinely terrifying and I was
worried about that happening
again but I have definitely found that I
am improving I've been out multiple
times while I've been here to get lunch
although it has been nerve wracking
there's not been as bad as it has been
the last time I was here that's maybe
the positive I can end this one to make
you feel like everything's gonna be all
right
I hope it will been but um you know
we'll see I'm just doing my best and
yeah if you're going through similar
things as well feel yeah I really do and
yeah sorry that this was a rambling miss
but I couldn't really just fill it the
right way to do it
hope you have a great day and I'll see
you in the next one of these whatever
that might be who knows these days eh
thanks for watching bye guys